After flipping a coin 100 times, you tally
up 42 heads and 58 tails. You expected a 50/50
distribution. Does this mean the coin is unfair?
This video is part of the Probability and
Statistics video series. Many events and phenomena
are probabilistic. Engineers, designers, and
architects often use probability distributions
to predict system behavior.
Hi, my name is Lourdes Aleman, and I am a
research scientist in the HHMI Education Group
in the biology department at MIT. I also work
in the MIT Office of Educational Innovation
and Technology. I helped develop the Star
Genetics software featured in this video.
Before watching this video, you should know
what a probability distribution is and be
familiar with basic genetics vocabulary including
genotype, phenotype, homozygous, and heterozygous.
You should also know how to use Punnett squares
to predict the expected results of Mendelian
crosses.
After watching this video, you will be able
to apply Chi square hypothesis testing to
experimental data obtained from genetic experiments.
Going back to question of whether or not our
coin is fair, it turns out there is a statistical
tool that can help us. Statistical tests can
be used to determine if sample data can be
assumed to come from a population that has
a certain distribution.
Today, we will use a statistical test called
the Chi Square Test for Goodness of Fit.
The Chi Square test is used to analyze categorical
data. In other words, the test compares a
sample of data collected about an event to
expected values.
In our coin-flipping example, our categories
are heads and tails. An event is one coin flip.
Our sample is 100 events.
We expect
that the coin should have a 50/50 chance of
being heads or tails in any given event. The
question we are trying to answer is – does
our sample come from the 50/50 population
distribution we expect?
What we have just done is state our null hypothesis
about the coin flipping experiment. The Chi
square statistic tests this null hypothesis.
We also need to state an alternative hypothesis.
The alternative hypothesis is simply that
the data do not come from the specified 50/50
population distribution.
Before we can test our hypothesis, we need
to calculate a Chi square statistic.
This statistic measures the discrepancy between
observed counts and expected counts.
Each term in our summation finds the deviation,
or error, between observed and expected values
for each category. This deviation is squared
to obtain positive values. Otherwise, everything
would sum to zero because both our observed
and expected outcomes sum to the same value.
Each term in the summation is divided by the
expected value of the outcome as a way of
normalizing each difference.
The Chi square statistic lives in a distribution.
This is the Chi square distribution for any
sample that has two categories of data, or,
in other words, one degree of freedom.
If the outcome of an event can only fall into
one of two categories, we only need to know
how many events fell into one category in
order to determine how many fell into the
other category.
The Chi square distribution is actually a
set of distributions, each for a different
number of degrees of freedom.
If we look at these distributions, the x-axis
is chi-squared values and the y-axis is relative
frequency. You might also notice that these
distributions are positively skewed. This
makes sense for a couple of reasons:
The Chi squared statistic is always positive.
Larger and larger Chi squared values indicate
larger discrepancies between observed and
expected values. While possible, these large
discrepancies are less probable if the null
hypothesis is true. If we calculate the Chi
square test statistic for the coin flipping
experiment, we get 2.56.
How do we interpret this number? First, we
need to look at the appropriate Chi-squared distribution.
In the coin flipping experiment, there are
two possible outcomes: heads or tails.
If we know how many heads were flipped, we can
calculate the number of tails flipped.
So, we only have one degree of freedom.
Let’s refer to the Chi square distributions
for one degree of freedom.
We can compare our test statistic to the distribution
to see if we have support for our null hypothesis
or if we need to reject it.
What will our criterion for support or rejection
of our null hypothesis be?
While this is a fairly arbitrary choice, in many fields, a
result is said to not differ significantly
from expectations if it has a 1 in 20 chance
of happening.
In other words, if the difference between
the observed result and the expected result
is small enough, we would expect to see it
1 in 20 times, which is a probability of 0.05.
This probability is called the level of significance.
If a Chi square value has a probability of
occurring that is greater than our level of
significance, it lends support to our null
hypothesis. If a Chi square value has a probability
of occurring that is less than our level of
significance, we should reject the null hypothesis.
Using the Chi square distribution for 1 degree
of freedom, a chi square value of 2.56 has
a greater than the 5% probability of occurring
that we had set as our minimum.
This means that we fail to reject our null
hypothesis. In other words, what we observe
is close enough to what we expect that we
have confidence that our coin is fair.
Now, suppose you are planning an experiment
where you will cross mutant flies that are
heterozygous for a wingless phenotype to each
other. The wingless phenotype is dominant
relative to the wild-type winged phenotype.
Let’s use the notation Gg for the genotype
of the parent mutant flies.
In this case, the wild type, winged flies,
are homozygous recessive.
What percentage of flies resulting from a
cross of two heterozygous wingless mutants
would you expect to be wild type versus mutant?
Pause the video here and use a Punnett square
to justify your answer.
Performing this cross using a Punnett square,
you would expect a 3:1 ratio of mutant to
wild-type flies.
You perform the cross with the parental mutant
flies. The cross produces 50 progeny. 32 are
mutant and 18 are wild type.
So, only 64% of our flies are mutant, even
though you expected 75% of them to be mutant.
Although it is not what you expected, it doesn’t
seem that far off either.
You decide to continue mating your parental
mutant flies until you have 1000 progeny.
Surely, with this large a sample size, the
ratio of mutant to wild type flies will be
closer to what you expect.
Voila. Oh, wait a minute. Even with a 1000
progeny, our experiments still produce 68%
mutant and 32% wildtype flies.
Now you are really starting to wonder if you
can call this result “close enough” to
the expected outcome. We can use the Chi-square
test to evaluate the hypothesis that the observed
ratio of 68:32 is the same as the expected
ratio of 3:1.
Pause the video here, calculate the Chi square
test statistic, and determine the degrees
of freedom in your data.
You should have obtained 29.2 for your Chi
square value.
Because there are only two phenotypic outcomes
for your cross, there is only one degree of
freedom. Any fly that isn’t a mutant is
wild type and vice versa.
The Chi square distribution can also be presented
in tabular form. If you look at this table,
our experiment with one degree of freedom
and a Chi square value of 29.2 corresponds
to a probability that is much smaller than
0.05. Do you have support for the null hypothesis
or should you reject it? Pause the video here
and take a moment to think about it.
Because the ratio of progeny that you obtained
in your experiment has a probability of happening
that is less than our level of significance,
you should reject our null hypothesis.
This indicates that our discrepant results
are due to something more than just random
chance. A multitude of other factors could
be contributing to our results. For example,
there may be interactions with other genes
that you are not aware of. Or, environmental
factors could be playing a role. All we know
is that our null hypothesis of a 3:1 ratio
of mutant to wildtype flies is incorrect.
As a next step, you decide to go back and
review your notes to see if you can formulate
another plausible hypothesis.
Reviewing your Punnett square, you expected
to obtain this genotypic ratio in the F1 progeny.
If you were to select a GG mutant from the
F1 progeny and cross it with a gg wild-type
fly, you would expect that all of the progeny
would be mutants.
After attempting this cross with a variety
of flies from the F1 progeny that have a mutant
phenotype, it becomes clear that you cannot
find a mutant fly that when crossed with a
wild-type fly, produces all mutant progeny.
Somehow, you keep selecting heterozygous mutants.
You begin to suspect that the F1 population
does not contain the expected number of GG
flies!
Checking your lab notebook, you see a note
about an observation that you barely paid
attention to at the time. When you mated the
two parental mutant flies, there were a number
of dead embryos in your vial. A new hypothesis
is forming in your mind.
Can you come up with a hypothesis that may
explain the observations you have made through
these experiments? Pause the video here. Discuss
and justify your hypothesis with a classmate.
While there are many possible hypotheses,
one possible hypothesis is that the dead embryos
in your vial were the missing GG mutants.
It may be that the wingless trait when homozygous,
results in lethality.
This would result in a phenotypic ratio of
2:1 mutant to wild-type flies in the F1 progeny.
Again, you can use the Chi square test for
goodness of fit to test your new null hypothesis.
Going back to your data of 1000 progeny, use
the test to evaluate the null hypothesis.
Pause the video.
You should have obtained a Chi square value
of 0.36. For one degree of freedom, you fail
to reject your null hypothesis.
While you have support for your null hypothesis,
more experiments are needed to confirm the
idea that the GG genotype is lethal as you
suspect. The results from our Chi squared
test have led us to a reasonable next experiment
to perform.
In this video, you saw how the Chi-square
statistic can help us determine if our experimental
genetic data came from the expected population
distribution. Comparing observed values to
expected values helped us determine if deviations
in our data could be explained by random chance
or if our hypothesis needed revision.
The Chi-Square Test for Goodness of Fit is
just one statistical test of many that allows
us to determine how confident we are that
a sample of data comes from a population with
a certain distribution. It is important to
understand what these tests mean and how to
interpret their results, so that you know
their limitations and can make informed decisions.